- I mean, being from St. Louis,
like Bob, Bob Gibson and
Lou Brock were like the first Black
ballplayers that I was really introduced to.
- I'm from Atlanta and, you know, Hank Aaron,
you know, he was the Braves.
- A number of legendary,
you know, Black ballplayers passed away recently.
Hank Aaron being the latest.
Hall of Famer. Bob Gibson, Hall of
Famer. Lou Brock, Hall of Famer.
That's our legacy. In this sport,
you have to be great.
They were great.
And they did it the right way.
We look at activism now.
We know Hank Aaron's
legacy as a player.
But he didn't stop there.
He was coming off the likes of
Jackie Robinson and
those that have come before him. And
activism. I am more than a player.
I am more than a uniform.
- [Dwight Gooden:] I grew up in Tampa.
And in the late '60s, early
'70s, the Reds had spring training in Tampa.
I saw the Reds play, and I actually got to meet
Joe Morgan and know him personally.
Bob Gibson. Had many conversations with Bob.
Hank was the first guy
that I did a card show with in 1984.
I came up in '84 but became
a fan of baseball in '69.
You know, at that time, and just
watching the games, told my dad, seeing these guys play,
"Hey, Dad," like you said,
they did it the right way. On the field
and off the field. Those are my guys.
When I was around those guys, man, it brought out the little
kid in me because I remember watching those guys [inaudible].
But like you just said, those are the true
legends. And not only set examples on the field but off the field as well.
And they will be missed because that's the foundation.
And I'm glad hopefully to continue to do something throughout the season, during the summer so these guys can
get the recognition that they deserve.
- Growing up in the Bay Area, you had two options.
You had Little League or Oakland Babe Ruth.
And I played Oakland Babe Ruth.
But I would always say to myself,
you know, "Why is Babe Ruth
so revered
when Hank Aaron is the Home Run King?"
You know, it would never rest well with
me other than, you know, obviously the legend of
Babe Ruth, you know, drinking beers,
eating hot dogs, coming up on one leg
and hitting the ball out the ballpark.
I mean, that's legendary stuff. But
I'm like, but Hank didn't do that.
You know, he stayed
the course, was an activist,
you know, played in Milwaukee
and then over to Atlanta.
And he is the real Home Run King.
So why are we, why are we, you know,
revering, you know, Babe Ruth so much?
So my favorite player was Rickey Henderson,
who was chasing Lou Brock.
So that legacy was just
always being passed down.
You know, who was in front of me?
Who do I have to look up to?
And what do I have to chase?
What is the legacy
do I leave next?
You had those guys that we knew
about. Bob Gibson, legendary.
I mean, you let Willie
Mays tell it, Bob Gibson,
you know, didn't wear glasses on the
mound on purpose, but off the field he
had on glasses.
[Laughing]
So that's why he was flipping people up and down.
You know, Willie getting in a high-pitched voice, "Hey, you wear glasses?"
[Laughing]
You know, all the great legendary stories.
So, for me, it was,
you know, knowing that they did
it before me, knowing their story
and all the things that they went
through, how can I make my mark
so I don't disrespect them and their
legacy? Because it wasn't about me,
you know, in a uniform.
Yes,
I'm Black in a uniform
and I have to make my mark, but I'm making
my mark because I'm leaving a legacy.
I'm leaving,
I'm living in their legacy.
I'm living in their shadows.
- You know,
growing up and hearing the stories from my
uncle, who, my grandfather, so, they said
my grandfather actually played against
Hank Aaron in like some of the, before
Hank went to the Negro Leagues, I
guess he played in like these
- [Offscreen:] The barnstorming days.
- [Ryan Howard:] kinda old-model leagues in Alabama.
And my grandfather played against him.
So my uncle would tell me these stories
all the time about, you know, watching
my grandfather and playing against
Hank Aaron, and all this kind of stuff.
So watching what he did
and actually being able to
get a Hank, an award named after Hank
Aaron is kind of, it's surreal. Because it's kind of
like, I feel like I can't even take this
because of what this man accomplished.
Like, I'm not even on the same level
or playing field as a Hank Aaron.
To have 755 home runs, over 2,200 RBI.
Like, that was the bar.
And as a power hitter,
you're like, as soon as you
get to league, I'm chasing Hank Aaron.
I'm trying to eclipse him. Because that
was the bar that was set.
Like, stopping and thinking about my
career now, like 382 home runs. Man,
that's a lot of home runs.
755 home runs, bro?
That is insanity.
It's insanity.
To be that consistent,
to be able to do what he did
over the course of his career.
It's what we all strive for.
Like for me, it was kind of like,
I just want to do my part to say
thank you for paving the way.
And that's going to be me going out
here every single day, playing the game
the right way, preparing myself the
right way and trying to go out here and
do things to the best of my ability.
Because that's what you did.
That's what these guys did.
And Bob Gibson and Hank Aaron, those
guys, Lou Brock, it's the precedent
that's set. It's that pride of being
a Black baseball player to where now
it's the phenomenon of,
you know, there's very few
and far between, but to see Kyle,
to see Devin, to see some other young,
Black ballplayers in the game today,
the future is very, very bright.
- Devin,
We'll start with you. What is
your history of the game? Generally as we get
further and further away from those
generations, the less they're talked about.
So how did you learn about, you
know, the greats in the game
in light of the ones that we've
lost, that have passed recently?
- [Devin Williams:] I mean, being from St.
Louis, like Bob, Bob Gibson
and Lou Brock was like the first
Black ballplayers that I was really
introduced to, you know. I grew up
watching the old black and white films of
Bob Gibson, you know, striking out
18 or whatever it was in a
game, you know. The things like that.
Lou Brock just, you know,
being the game-changer that he
was in all facets of the game.
I mean, those guys really kind of were
the first ones to, you know, that I could
see in myself, you know, that I'm watching
on TV and I can see the similarities
between us, you know. Whether you like
it or not, you just, you pay attention
more to people that look like you.
Then that kind of led into, growing up,
I read Doc's autobiography growing up.
You know, he's a pitcher, I'm a pitcher.
I identify with him, you know, and that
just kind of kept it rolling.
Getting into when
I actually started playing,
then I was following you two.
You know, Ryan being from St.
Louis, you played shortstop, which
was what I played at the time.
You know, I had to have all your cleats.
You know, I tried to have the batting gloves
you had, man. Like, all that stuff. But,
yeah, I mean, there's definitely, it's,
to me, it's an honor to be like
one of those guys, that some kid
right now is going to be doing the
same thing I'm doing right now
hopefully in 15, 20 years.
- [Kyle Lewis:] I'm from Atlanta and, you know, Hank
Aaron, you know, he was the Braves.
You know, when I grew up, you know,
Hank Aaron was the gold
standard for everything hitting.
being from the South,
You know,
looking up to him, and he
would always, you know, make efforts
to be around, be in the community.
And I got the opportunity to meet him
one time, and I just remember being,
chills going through my body, you know?
And so it's, you know, different
experiences you have, you know,
throughout your lifetime, and watching
you guys, you know, with the Phillies.
You guys' legendary runs and
screaming at the TV and whatnot.
Man, these things that they
set, they set the table.
And so I would run around my house,
you know, doing, you know, Ryan Howard
home run trots, you know, and, trying to
see, you know, what I, how I was going to celebrate when I
crossed home plate and things like that.
So, you know, hopefully we can just
continue to be the next in line in
whatever way that may be, you know.
And that may not be being the greatest
player ever, but, you know, just in
the way that we represent ourselves.
Talk to people, play
the game the right way,
you know, and wear the uniform the right way.
So I definitely just try to
pick up on those little things
and continue to
give my respect whenever I can.
But Hank Aaron
was a tough one to see
go cuz, man, he was the gold standard
really.
- Young gems on here.
You know what? This game is in
some very good hands.
I mean, if you two are setting
a standard of what it's like to
be a Black baseball player, this
game is in some really good hands.
If you guys are the future, I really
love the way baseball is going
for us Black athletes in baseball, for real.